hello everyone it's seven o'clock this
is Sky News breakfast now you have to go
a long way back to find a bigger
election win for labor than the one they
achieved last night in Chester but is it
big enough for the party to be confident
that they're on the road to power we'll
be discussing that throughout the
program plus transport secretary Mark
Harper will meet rail union bosses today
but there's no guarantee it'll help to
stop the strikes so we'll be live in
Chester and live at the rmt headquarters
it's Friday the 2nd of December
I hereby declare that Samantha Kate
Dixon has been duly elected as the
Member of Parliament for the city of
Chester
a good night for labor as they
convincingly beat the conservatives in
the Chester by-election
unit officials say the transport
secretary will meet the head of the rmt
rail Union today to try to prevent a
series of Nationwide strikes
with strikes set to bring the rail
network to stand still over much of
Christmas commuters will be hoping that
the government will be able to hammer
out a deal with the rmt Union to end the
dispute
a Ukraine official says between 10 and
13 000 of its soldiers have been killed
so far in the war with Russia
on a day of shocks in Qatar Germany and
Belgium are both knocked out of the
World Cup
well good morning from the World Cup in
Qatar Germany are going home knocked out
to the group stages for the second
tournament in a row
the Royal Rifts The Prince and Princess
of Wales continue their U.S trip
battling against the high-profile
publicity campaign launched by Harry and
Megan
also how to look good at this year's
Christmas lunch Miley and class will
tell us why she's a fan of Christmas
jumpers
[Music]
hello very good morning to you labor has
won the Chester by election with the
biggest swing from the conservatives to
labor since 1997. Samantha Dixon
retained the seat for her party with a
61 share of the vote and it's the first
public votes since Boris Johnson and
this trust were ousted from number 10
and Miss Dixon used her victory speech
to warn that the conservatives were on
borrowed time
I've just talked in my acceptance speech
about the difficulty that people people
in Chester are experiencing in their
lives day to day and I think
the voters feel very strongly about that
and I think that's probably the reason
why we've seen such a significant uh
increase in in Labor's share
so let's take a look at the breakdown of
the results with labor winning by a
majority of nearly 11
000 votes her consecutive rival Liz Ward
law was in second place with
6335 the liberal Democrats Rob Hurd was
third increasing the party vote share
from the 2019 election and the result
represents a 13.8 swing from the Tories
to labor the sixth largest between the
parties at a by-election since
1945. the swinging weight Wakefield in
June was 12.7 percent
well our political correspondent Liz
Bates is in Chester for us this morning
so Liz Bates a healthy win then for
labor presumably they're pretty
satisfied with this result
yeah big win uh for labor here in
Chester they are pretty happy about the
results of early Christmas present if
you like
um for them it's quite interesting as
well in this seat because this is not we
are in the north but this is not a red
wall seat by any stretch of the
imagination this is much more like a
sort of Swing seat it was traditionally
conservative it went labor in 1997 back
to the conservatives in 2012 and it's
2010 under David Cameron and then it's
been labor ever since usually very small
majorities but this is a their biggest
majority here ever almost 11 000 votes
on percentage uh share as well it's
their highest result ever here so
they're really pleased with this a 14
swing away from the conservative party
which we'll be worrying for them of
course what it means for labor is
they've been doing extremely well in the
polls and they will have been wanting
particularly after the Wakefield
by-election to see that replicated again
when it comes to voters turning out for
them at The Ballot Box because of course
that's the only poll in the end that
matters and they've seen that happen
today of course if this was extrapolated
across the country it would see them in
government but that it this is of course
just a by-election and things are very
different when it comes to a general
election but they will be feeling very
confident and positive thinking about
the next general election a couple of
years time what it means for the
conservative party I mean Rishi sunak
won't be happy with this result but I
think it probably won't be seen as a
reflection of his Premiership he just
simply hasn't been in long enough to
have had much of an impact here and of
course
um there was a lot of damage done when
it came to conservative support up and
down the country during the final months
of Boris Johnson's Premiership and and
then of course a sort of hemorrhaging a
collapse under Liz truss and
quasi-quarters what it does show Rishi
sunak is the level of challenge that he
faces this is the type of scene that if
he wants to stay in government remain
prime minister he should be competing
for well he's not competing very well
here at the moment and he will have to
turn that round in the next couple of
years it's a very dismal economic
backdrop if he wants to remain in
government
Liz thanks very much indeed so let's get
a view on all of this we can speak to
the conservative pollster Lord Robert
Hayward a very good morning to you nice
to see you I mean label we're expected
to win this by-election weren't they but
what do you make of the result and how
much they want it by have they got
reason to really celebrate today oh yes
they have to be pleased they've got over
60 percent swings 13 it it's good for
cheer for the labor party no question
about it but the conservatives will be
relieved they got over 20 there's a
psychological thing there and it's not
quite as bad as the opinion polls have
been suggesting so pleasure on the labor
side relief a bit on the conservative
side well yes and you talk about what
the the national opinion polls are
suggesting if they were to match that
they would have had a 17 swing labor
from the conservatives so is that a
source of disappointment would you
expect them to match those National
polls there's somewhere in the range and
there's no question that conservatives
will be relieved that it's it is below
what one might have expected rather than
above but labor quite reasonably can say
well the turnout was only 41 it was 70
percent of the last general election so
I think generally as expected no shocks
but definitely satisfaction for the
labor party well yes and not great for
the Tories either I mean this is not
something that's good news for varishi
sunac to wake up to he's pretty fresh in
the job how much of the blame should he
take for this I think he'll take the
view he's been in the job for just over
a month he knows the challenges the Tory
party know the challenges and it to a
large extent the collapse of the Tories
in the opinion polls
arose from the events right through the
summer into the Autumn and he will say
I've got to put put it behind me
which is what the message has been over
the last few weeks get on with the job
re-establish the economy deal with the
big issues whether it's immigration or
strikes or the NHS and convince the
government the next big electoral hurdle
will be a huge raft of opinion of local
elections next May and that's where the
real attention will turn to I mean some
people say that at this stage in a prime
ministeria ship that's not a word but
you know what I mean when you've taken
on the top job yes and so early on in
that job you might get a little bit of a
boost you might people might say look
there's a fresh leader let's give them a
chance no I think the sense has been
that the Tories have had a very very bad
summer uh into the Autumn uh he's taken
over an incredibly difficult
circumstances he knows what he wants to
do the question is whether he can
actually do it
um he's got a very very slight bounce
because
the opinion polls the Tories were in the
bottom of a very deep barrel and the
opinion poles showed that the Tories
have lifted themselves a bit off that
this result shows a bit better than the
opinion bowls are showing
um so he might have had a slight bounce
he stopped the Tories just collapsing
into irrelevance
how worried will those MPS in the red
wall the so-called red wall see it's not
far from Chesterfield today oh it's not
just the red wall I sat in this studio a
few weeks ago and said that give them
the opinion polls the Tories couldn't be
clear that they'd got any safe seat so
it's not just red wall all MPS all three
MPS will be looking at this result
they'll be looking at local government
by-elections because they're low they
are those each week and um being
concerned there's no question about it
the Tories have got to make progress but
what kind of progress can they make when
we're heading into a winter of so far
we've got lots of strikes planned but
we've also got this terrible cost of
living crisis where bills are just going
up and up how can the Tories make any
real Headway before those local
elections there's no question they have
a real Challenge on on their hands but
having said that
um Rishi comes across to the public at
large as managerial his ratings are way
ahead of the Tory parties at his rating
things which will worry the labor party
are on a par with kirstelma depending on
which poll you actually look at so he is
showing that there is potential but cost
of living and Strikes clearly big issues
but
the end of my road today petrol prices
down again at the local petrol station
so there are some indications that there
are opportunities there for the Tory
party but Richie has to convince the
public at large that he can manage out
of this crisis whichever crisis one's
looking at and there's a lot of them and
just a quick question I'm curious to
know what you make of the fact that
Boris Johnson has said that he does
intend to stand again next time around
the Tories have set this deadline
haven't they for MPS to come forward and
say whether or not they're going to
stand again we've seen some of the
younger MPS deciding not to Boris
Johnson says he will what do you think
that does to the psyche of the party
knowing that the former leader still
intends to stay on I I think it probably
says I want to continue to serve because
you'd be asking me that almost the
opposite question if he'd announced that
he was going to stand down isn't this a
comment so it's natural I think for
Boris Boris is a natural politician he
wants to be in the political world and
there foreign
nothing let's take a quick look at
what's making the front pages of the
morning papers and the express asks
Harry do you really hate your family so
much
the mirror simply goes with a headline
Royal crisis deepens
the eye warns that Royal Mail could
struggle to cope with demand over
Christmas following a backlog caused by
strike action
the guardian claims an exclusive with
news that health union Chiefs are
meeting to plan joint strikes
strikes leave the times as well with
appeals from ministers to rail unions to
call a truce in their industrial action
and the Daily Mail carries extracts from
the former Health secretary Matt
Hancock's new book in which he reveals a
plan to release thousands of prisoners
was under discussion at the height of
the pandemic
so I looked there at the front pages of
the morning Paper Strikes on some of
them and in fact unions officials say
that the leader of Britain's main rail
Union will meet the transport secretary
later on today as part of efforts to try
to prevent a series of Nationwide
strikes Mick Lynch from the rmt will
hold talks with Mark Harper after
warnings that the dispute will cost the
country billions of pounds in the run-up
to Christmas it's one of a series of
disputes resulting in strikes every day
in December other workers taking action
include nurses teachers and postal
workers
joins me now from the rmt headquarters
in central London so Elena how much hope
is there that these talks might produce
some kind of breakthrough
well Hugh Merriman the rail Minister
certainly hopes so he has called on the
union leaders to be altruist he could
cancel these strikes which are taking
place ahead of Christmas and in the New
Year traditionally time that's really
important for the hospitality industry
places like pubs restaurants shops
hoping to make a lot of the Christmas
trade and make up for the two very
difficult years they've had during the
pandemic but I think it's important to
note that the negotiations itself they
are not between the government and the
unions they're between the rail
companies and the unions the government
said that they would be there to
facilitate and support any deal but not
to negotiate on the deal itself and when
it comes to the impact on Hospitality
well the trade industry body UK
Hospitality says that on strike days it
will cost them 1.5 billion pounds it's a
devastating impact and if these strikes
do go ahead they will be the largest in
30 years a huge economic impact huge
impact on commuters as well now the
unions are placing the blame on the
government saying that they actually
managed to find deals with uh devolved
of government administrations in
Scotland and in Wales but there was no
such help from Westminster they're
saying that the government is showing a
lack of urgency considering that these
strikes are set to start in just a
couple of weeks and rail companies are
actually saying if there's no solution
in the next few days it would be really
hard to reinstate the timetable so even
if a deal was found later on in December
there would still be disruption and
business it would still suffer okay
Melina and a fascinating one to watch of
course thanks very much indeed
an advisor to the Ukrainian President
zielinski says somewhere between 10 and
13 000 soldiers have been killed in the
war against Russia the figures from
senior official mikailo podolkiak
appears to be the first estimate of the
Dead since August
last month the U.S said they believed
that more than a hundred thousand
Russian soldiers had been killed or
wounded in Ukraine so far
what U.S President Biden says he's
prepared to meet Vladimir Putin if the
Russian president shows any interest in
ending the war in Ukraine he made the
comments during a state visit by the
French president president French
president macron where the war in
Ukraine has dominated talks during a
joint press conference after their
meeting President Biden said he would
talk to the Russian president if he
showed willingness to end the war but
that is yet to happen
I have no immediate plans to contact Mr
Putin
Mr Putin is we choose my words very
carefully
I'm prepared to speak with Mr Putin
if in fact there is an interest in him
society and he's looking for a way to
end the war he hasn't done that yet
if that's the case
in consultation with my French and my
NATO friends I'll be happy to sit down
with Putin to see what he wants has in
mind
let me tell you that we will never urge
the ukrainians to make a compromise
which will not be acceptable for them
because
they are so brave and they defend
precisely
their lives their nation and our
principles
and because it will never build a
sustainable peace
if we want a sustainable peace
we have to respect ukrainians to decide
the moment and the conditions in which
they will negotiate
about their territory and their future
gunkel is in Doha forth this morning
Alistair what a night of football that
was
I really was I mean this world cup is
not failing to disappoint on the pitch
much of the time particularly as we're
getting into the nitty-gritty uh of what
are effectively uh knockout matches for
many of them the last ground last round
of group games is seeing some pretty
frenetic football as teams try and
Scramble for the top two places in a
group in order to progress not so for
Germany it was a very strange match they
took the lead early on and they look by
Far and Away the dominant side against
Costa Rica and then early in the second
half Costa Rica scored twice to go in
front but it wasn't just what was
happening at that match it was what was
happening as well against Japan versus
Spain and a similar thing happened Spain
went in the lead and then Japan got two
quick goals to take that lead over and
for a few minutes it looks as though
both Germany and Spain were going to go
home Japan held on for that Victory a
2-1 victory over Spain that means they
topped the group uh Germany then found
some goals in them and they managed to
quite convincingly beat Costa Rica but
it wasn't enough they finished bottom of
the group and for the second tournament
in a row they're going home normally
such a Dependable World Cup team four
times World Cup winners the scourge of
many in England side in tournaments uh
going back through the decades but not
to be this time they are leaving Qatar
early and instead it is Japan and Spain
who progress in that group to the next
round
how many Tristan turns Ali what's next
thanks very much indeed
they'll come here on the show at half or
seven we're going to be joined by the
director of policy at National energy
action as well as a mother struggling to
pay her bills as new figures reveal the
millions of households will be in fuel
poverty by April
[Music]
it isn't the UK in a better position to
deal with another pandemic I'll be
speaking to Clive Diggs who's a former
chair of the UK vaccine task force
but right now let's take a look at some
of those other headlines and two
teenagers have been charged with the
murders of 16 year olds Ken solanki and
Charlie bitolo in southeast London
kinsalanki was stabbed in thamesmead and
Charlie patola was found a mile away in
Abbey Wood on Saturday
members of the victims of a hospital
worker who abused more than a hundred
corpses could receive tens of thousands
of pounds in compensation David Fuller
was handed a life sentence last year for
the murders of two women in Tunbridge
Wells in 1987. he also pleaded guilty to
sexual offenses against 101 deceased
females in a hospital Mortuary
the cost of the Metropolitan Police are
dealing with recent environmental
protests is more than five and a half
million pounds met commissioner Samar
Rowley gave the figures during a meeting
with the Prime Minister and Home
Secretary called to discuss how to deal
with demonstrations by the group just
stop oil
the U.S Congress has passed emergency
legislation stopping Railway workers
from going on strike the Senate approved
a bill binding workers and rail
companies to a proposed settlement
NHS officials have warned Mental Health
Services in England are being left to
fail the NHS Confederation and Center
for mental health says many patients
often only get the help they need when
they're in crisis
football legend Pele has posted on
social media for the first time since
going back into Hospital the former
Brazil Striker thanked fans and players
who sent him messages of support from
the World Cup in Qatar
scientists say they believe an asteroid
may have created a so-called mega
tsunami across the surface of Mars
billions of years ago researchers at the
planetary Science Institute in the
United States say a giant wave measuring
up to 250 meters in height caused a
crater on the planet's surface more than
100 kilometers wide
Now The Prince and Princess of Wales
will finish their visit to the United
States today after a trip which has been
overshadowed by allegations of racism in
Buckingham Palace there was also
controversy when Netflix released the
first images from a new documentary
about the life of the Duke and Duchess
of Sussex Midway through the Royal tour
our Royal correspondent Laura bundock
reports now from Boston
[Music]
they're soldiering on but there's no
escaping the Buckingham Palace racism
row
day two in Boston also overshadowed The
Prince and Princess of Wales want to be
heard but it's hard a warm welcome
though at this community project the
energy was going um I didn't I didn't
feel any any negative Vibes
um as far it definitely shows that they
you know are
not what um the media probably shows
about them you know as far as the bad
light and um yeah so you know as far as
me thinking out there racist I don't I
don't want to say that
this was their day to Champion causes
they care about but it was also the day
Harry and Megan dropped this
why did you want to make this
documentary the trailer to their
much-hyped Netflix series I had to do
everything I could to protect my family
[Music]
mistakes were this high
doesn't make more sense to hear our
story from us
these short sentences say so much Harry
and Megan on the war path and another
torpedo for the wales's trip
they're outwardly enjoying themselves
but you can only imagine what they're
thinking and then for the trailer to
come out that was that's to me is
backstabbing let everyone have their
moment and Kate Catherine and William
right now The Prince and Princess of
Wales have their moment here in Boston
to make a change for the better and
that's where they should stand we all
got to work together we got to unite and
stay together
um doesn't matter the black white
Spanish doesn't matter we all got to
work together and unite you worry that
the royal family are racist no
absolutely not this whole visit is being
eclipsed by other events interestingly
the racism Rao isn't really resonating
here but people are fascinated by the
royal family mostly though the Dynamics
and the dramas
and the prince and princess of Wales
probably wishing there was a lot less of
both Laura bundock Sky News in Boston
that's technical what the weather's
doing there
well this year brought the third warmest
Autumn on record but it's a cold start
to the meteorological winter it's murky
and chilly for many now with some dense
fog around mainly across Southwest
Britain and it'll stay rather gray
through the morning with fog slowly
lifting but there'll be some sunshine
around Ireland Northern Ireland West
Wales and Cornwall look most favored
Northern parts will have some
patchy-like rain mainly Southern and
Eastern Scotland well East Anglia and
the southeast will be at risk of showers
welcome back let's remind you of our top
stories here this morning a good night
for labor as they convincingly beat the
conservatives in the Chester by-election
Union officials say the transport
secretary will meet the head of the rmt
rail Union today to try to prevent a
series of Nationwide strikes
Ukrainian official says between 10 and
13 000 of its soldiers have been killed
so far in the war with Russia
[Music]
so labor has won the Chester by-election
with the biggest swing from the
conservatives to labor since 1997. well
a little earlier I spoke to the
conservative pollster Lord Robert
Hayward and asked him if labor have
reason to celebrate after their
by-election Victory last night
they have to be pleased they've got over
60 percent swings 13
it's good for cheer for the labor party
no question about it but the
conservatives will be relieved they got
over 20 there's a psychological thing
there and it's not quite as bad as the
opinion polls have been suggesting so
pleasure on the labor side relief a bit
on the conservative side
well our political correspondence Amanda
acres is here with me morning to you so
where does this result leave the tour is
Amanda well I think it's interesting
what Lord Hayward was saying there
really I think for some in the
conservative party given the scandals of
Boris Johnson's Administration the
divisive leadership uh campaign over the
summer disaster of the mini budget now
all the bad economic news with the
Autumn statement the cost of living
crisis many would have feared it could
have been even worse particularly given
the national polling is showing labor 17
even 25 ahead of the Tories
um governing parties do traditionally
lose by-elections equally it's not good
for morale potentially we're going to
see many more of these coming down the
track especially as Boris Johnson's
looking to in his resignation honors
list Elevate some of his MPS to the
Lords
um Ferris sunak has only been in office
as prime minister sort of six weeks or
so it doesn't really give the impression
of a government in control with his
waiver strike actions we're seeing in
the run-up to Christmas later today
there's a meeting between the transport
secretary mark Carper and Mick Lynch of
the rmt's second meeting they had one
last week which was described as quite
positive yesterday Eddie Dempsey of the
rmt told Kate Burley that he was hopeful
a deal could potentially be struck he
talked quite warmly almost about the
kind of change in tone under the new
Administration certainly a bit more
pragmatic yesterday in the House of
Commons Hugh Merriman the rail Minister
was talking about the impact on small
businesses calling on the unions to be
altruistic call off the strengths in the
run-up to Christmas potentially UK
Hospitality warning of an impact of
around 1.5 billion pounds lost to the
industry because of all these strikes
particularly after all the impact of
covert we've seen in the last few years
and suggesting that the government would
see what it could do to help as well not
such a conciliatory tone coming from the
Department of Health though in terms of
the NHS strikes suggestions we could see
some coordinated action across the board
there government prime minister
yesterday Health secretary insisting
their demands are unaffordable the 19
percent increase that the nurses for
example are calling forward cost 10
billion pounds a year saying that's not
something we can do equally we know long
long waitingness in the NHS seven
million people waiting for treatment
ambulances yesterday in some areas
taking an hour and 40 minutes to get to
people I think the more we see stories
coming out about how this is affecting
people lives potentially lost yes
potentially that's going to lead to more
anger against the unions but I think
fundamentally the government will really
need to look like they have a plan to
stop this and bring the country down
lots of pressures there yeah Amanda
thanks very much indeed
now eight months on from Russia's
Invasion and people across Ukraine are
learning to cope with the
unpredictability of War some have
compared their experience to London
during the Blitz in the second world war
and say they shared The Same Spirit of
defiance what sky is security and
defense editor Deborah Haynes sent this
report from Kiev
life goes with hungry mouths to feed
it almost looks ordinary
but everyone here knows another wave of
Russian missile strikes could come at
any moment targeting energy supplies and
turning off the power yet no one runs
away
this couple has stayed in the capital
since the first day of the full-scale
wars
many liken their resilience to what the
UK endured during the Blitz in World War
II yeah
Kiev has been enjoying a lull in Russian
attacks this week after waves of strikes
caused widespread blackouts
the chances are it won't last but no
one's panicking
this was the response to an air raid
warning at a forum where the mayor was
due to speak
is under the air raid alert but we are
on the ground we are in the shelter and
we will continue our work Vitali
kitschko urged residents to be prepared
for anything even long periods without
power the Russians to bring try to bring
depression of citizens instead them and
I talked to our citizens they very angry
and ready to stay and ready to fight
it's a sentiment held by even the most
frail
a determination to defy the dangers and
dig in
Deborah Haynes Sky News Kiev
Now new figures revealed that 8.4
million UK households will be in fuel
poverty by next April that's up from 4.5
million last October the charity
National energy action says those in
fuel poverty will include 6.3 million
people with a disability and 1.8 million
carers
well joining me now to discuss all of
this is Peter Smith the director of
policy at National energy action and I'm
also joined by Charmaine who's a mother
of eight who's struggling to pay her
energy bills and we're respecting her
privacy so we're hearing her voice
rather than seeing her on screen so
welcome to both of you Charmaine to you
first of all we're hearing about
millions of households being in debt
because of energy bills give us a sense
of how you're managing and how you've
found trying to pay your own
um so it's been really hard
um as you said I'm a mother of eight and
the other day I had to top up 90 pounds
on my gas and electric just to get me
above the emergency just so I had
something in my house I'm having to cut
back on wash loads I'm having to cut
back on my shopping
um petrol I'm having to cut back on
everything which is minimizing what I
can do for the children and with the
children I've got a birthday coming up
I've got Christmas and I'm just
scrimping and scraping trying to find
some extra money to help with that
because all the extra money that would
have gone to that is now going to my
energy bills
and Peter listening to Charmaine there
there'll be a lot of people saying
seeing a familiar picture that they'll
be suffering in the same kind of way
across the country today it won't there
um and at National energy action where
you are from of course you're saying
that there are going to be Millions more
facing Problems by next April just how
bad do you think this could get
well sadly we know that there's far too
many households about 6.7 million UK
households at the moment that are facing
the challenges that Charmaine was just
highlighting we know that that's going
to jump up to over a million households
from April when the government reduces
the support that it's making available
to to households to manage their energy
costs and it's a terrible situation
there's nothing more to cut back on
people have already been incredibly
Frugal and really the only choices that
they face are either to cut back
entirely to the detriment of their
health and well-being or get into
further debt so it's a terrible
situation which doesn't seem like it's
going to improve in the short term
well yes and Peter the government has
said it's going to scale back its energy
support scheme in April as you say to
make it more targeted so what would your
message to them be to make sure that the
most vulnerable people or people like
Charmaine who are finding it hard to pay
their bills now make sure they're
protected
well we know that the support of the
government are going to be making
available post April isn't going to be
sufficient to help the poorest and the
most vulnerable people approximately
one-third of um all households that
really need support aren't going to
receive anything more than the the three
thousand pound cap that the government
is putting in place from from April and
so they're going to see a huge increase
in their energy bills this is a time
where Energy prices are already at
record record highs so we would like to
see the government recognize that this
winter is going to be um tougher than
they imagined and provide more support
even in the remaining months of this
winter and then post April they need to
provide more targeted support
particularly for those households that
aren't all means-tested benefits we're
really concerned that low-income
households that aren't or means tested
benefits will not be adequately
protected post April
and Charmaine when the changes to the
energy support package come in in April
how worried are you that you might have
even less help and what would that do to
you if that was the case
um my I I do have a partner who works
um but I do also receive
um benefits because he's on a low income
um I have two children that I receive
disability for one of which has been
diagnosed with autism ADHD speech and
language and dyslexia
um so it's it's hard because I have to
have and she's got a hole in her heart
as well so my house has to be warm I
can't not have the heating on so I'm
scared that my daughter is going to end
up getting really sick all the time
um it's bad enough that they've taken a
lot of time off school at the moment
because they're getting sickness they've
got the runny noses the coughs and the
colds the flu
um because the house isn't as warm as it
needs to be because I just can't afford
to do it and if I'm like this now what
am I going to be like when all of this
all happens and we haven't got that
little bit of help even though we get
the 66 pounds a month that doesn't even
last a week anymore it it goes as quick
as it comes
and Peter I know you've helped a lot of
families like charmaine's in recent
weeks with their energy bills what kind
of pressures do you as a charity feel
under at the moment
well overall we're seeing an absolute
surging demand for the types of support
that we can provide as a relatively
small charity we've seen about 180
increase in the amount of people coming
to us compared to last last year uh
unfortunately it is placing huge strain
on our staff
um often hearing you know stories like
charmaine's um but even more
Grim situations
um where people don't feel that they're
able to adequately help help and support
people
um and particularly give them the
Adaptive support that they know is
desperately necessary so it is placing
huge strain on not just our organization
but organizations across the country
staying off your property awareness day
we are celebrating the work of those
organizations right across the country
that are doing so much to try and stem
the flood but really we do need to see
more support from national government if
if we're going to weather the the worst
of this crisis
well Peter Smith from National energy
action thanks very much indeed for your
time and thanks to to Charmaine thanks
so much for joining us and telling us a
little bit about your experience at the
moment
thank you and though the mother of a 14
year old boy who was stopped by police
says they left him traumatized Janet
Joseph told Sky News that the teenager's
education had been affected he no longer
wanted to play football with his friends
and he now distrusts officers well that
view is apparently widely shared a new
report has found that just 36 percent of
black children and teenagers have trust
in the police our correspondent Shimon
Freeman Powell reports
you may be wondering what the child in
this video did to deserve this young boy
but 14 year old Deshawn was simply
walking home from school please here
explain to a member of public that he
was stopped searched and pinned to the
ground because he matched the
description of a knife-wielding robber
DeSean was in his school uniform and the
only description that matched was the
color of desean's skin
they just snatched his mobile phone from
him they then proceeded to push him
against the railings and handcuff him
the way the incident was conducted is
now under investigation but Deshawn's
mum says it won't change the lasting
impact it's had on her son
Deshawn's education has been massively
affected by this um we've had to
organize transport to get him back and
forth from school he no longer goes out
with his friends anymore
um and of course there's a big distrust
the Met police say that stop and search
is a crucial tool in helping to reduce
crime but that it doesn't underestimate
the impact it can have on young people
recognizing the importance of using the
tool with dignity and respect
but that's not enough for Janet she's
petitioning for a change in law which
would see the police adopt a
child-centered approach to these
scenarios the bill would support stop
and search as long as it's done the
right way
Jaden is sympathetic to police he
understands that they have a job to do
but at just 15 years old he's been
stopped three times already to be honest
the situation I did have was a bit
humiliating because at the same time
there's people coming out of school
parents around kids adults and it was
just a bit embarrassing
a child's first encounter with police is
vitally important because it will shape
the way they view them for the rest of
their lives but a new report by
independent think tankers farm that when
it comes to black children the level of
trust in police is alarmingly low
73 percent of young people trusted the
police but only 36 percent of black
children trust the police
and whilst 87 percent of white children
would call the police if they believe
they're in danger only 56 percent of
black Caribbean children would call
police
how did you I put these findings to
deputy chief Constable Tyron Joyce he's
developing a plan of action to tackle
some of these issues
as a dad I feel a sense of Shame as a
police officer I feel a sense of Shame
because every member of the community
needs to feel protected the only thing
that I would say in this plan is there
is concrete activity to demonstrate that
we're being fair to demonstrate
proportionality to give that level of
reassurance but before building the
foundations of trust the police May
first have to confront and repair the
mistakes of the past shiman Freeman
Powell Sky News
let's take a look now some of the days
of our headlines and the president of
South Africa is facing calls to resign
after he was accused of corruption a
report examining claims Cyril ramaphosa
covered up the theft of more than 3
million pounds in cash from his farm
described the president's explanations
as improbable
an Australian man who became the subject
of a popular crime podcast has been
jailed for 24 years for his wife's
murder 74 year old Chris Dawson was
convicted in August after Decades of
speculation about Lynette Dawson's 1982
disappearance a judge rule Dawson killed
his wife so he could continue his
relationship with his teenage lover and
babysitter
we're going to check on the weather now
well this year brought the third warmest
Autumn on record but it's a cold start
to the meteorological winter it's murky
and chilly for many now with some dense
fog around mainly across South West
Britain and it'll stay rather gray
through the morning with fog slowly
lifting but there will be some sunshine
around